doctors say the American college student
released by North Korea has suffered
severe brain damage the cause of otto
warmbier injuries is unknown doctors in
Cincinnati though have refuted North
Korea's claims that the 22 year old fell
into a coma after contracting botulism
he was held for nearly 18 months
Michelle Miller is here with details of
his condition Michelle good morning good
morning doctors describe warmbier as
being in a state of unresponsive
wakefulness a condition where patients
are conscious but unable to respond
although the circumstances of his
injuries remain unknown one thing is for
certain
North Korea's version of what happened
to him isn't adding up new video from
otto warmbier family shows him alongside
members of his tour group in north korea
before his arrest nearly 18 months later
the 22 year old was returned to his
family on a stretcher in a comatose like
state I'm so proud of Otto my son who
has been in a pariah regime for the last
18 months brutalized and terrorized
wearing the same jacket as son ward as
trial Fred warmbier described the moment
they were finally reunited I knelt down
by his side and I hugged him and I told
him I missed him and I was so glad that
he made it home
doctors say they don't know what caused
warm beers injuries but said Thursday
the brain scans reveal they were likely
caused by a sudden stopping of the heart
he shows no signs of understanding
language responding to verbal commands
or awareness of his surroundings North
Korean officials claim that warmbier
fell into a coma shortly after he was
imprisoned last March after contracting
botulism and taking a sleeping pill on
Thursday doctors confirmed that no
traces could be found
he has no signs of infection or
dysfunction of the major non
neurological organs I made the worst
mistake of my life
warmbier was sentenced to 15 years hard
labor for committing a hostile act
against the regime after a change in
administration's and months of quiet
diplomacy we are glad he's home rejoined
with his family the State Department
secured his release upon learning of his
condition last week these things are
tough to process but he's with us and
we're trying to make him comfortable and
we want to be a part of his life warm
beers medical team said that while
unresponsive his vital signs are stable
and he's able to breathe without
supplemental oxygen in terms of his
long-term chances for improvement
doctors have declined to comment
his family's request Jeff Michelle thank
you very much